welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity house oversight committee
chairman James Comer is sounding the
alarm over possible witness intimidation
in the hunter Biden probe he says some
witnesses are now fearing for their
lives and are afraid to come forward so
what does that mean for the IRS
whistleblower accusing the government of
interfering with the investigation into
Hunter's taxes well during recent
Congressional testimony the IRS
commissioner promised there would be no
retaliation for anyone making
allegations against the agency here now
with the latest on all of this is house
oversight committee chairman James Comer
uh representative Comer thank you very
much for being here with me tonight
normally when I am guest hosting for
Sean I'm the one that tends to bite you
and uh but you're such a very good sport
and you're doing a great job and this
issue has become just dramatically
serious the hunter Biden thing is really
about Joe Biden and that that family and
the corruption of that family but it's
also about the security of this country
and if our agencies have been weaponized
against the American people these are
serious allegations how do you how do
you see this when it comes to the nature
of threats that might might may have
already been issued and what are we
going to do about it
well it's very concerning and I'm
sounding the alarm publicly we know that
some on Hunter Biden's legal team have
made contact with some people that we've
been communicating with to get
information we know that some Hunter
Biden legal team have reached out and
communicated with some of the people
that and institutions that we've
subpoenaed we know that people within
the Biden Administration have reached
out and expressed their disappointment
with some of the people that have been
subpoenaed and some of the people that
are cooperating with us and this is very
concerning because this is an
investigation about public corruption at
the highest levels this is an
investigation to determine whether or
not our white house and our and this
administration's compromised because of
the millions and millions of dollars
they've taken from adversaries around
the world so uh we've got a situation
where there are more and more people
coming forward and we're very thankful
for the IRS whistleblower and I'm pretty
confident in the next few weeks we're
going to have more whistleblowers come
forward so it's very important that our
whistleblowers are protected at the
Democrat politicians the media and the
legal team for the Biden family they
need to be very careful in not
intimidating our Witnesses because we
need to get the truth and present the
facts to the American people you know in
the normal World sir if you are
intimidating Witnesses during an
investigation that would be a crime is
there in talking about it publicly is
important but it kind of also proves the
point of why we need to investigate this
family because this is part and parcel
of the corruption when you're going out
there trying to scare people into not
talking is there anything else we can do
to keep this from continuing to make
these whistleblowers feel safe enough to
come forward
well we're sounding the alarm as I said
uh we're we have every Republican eye in
Washington DC on The Whistleblower with
the IRS that's going to come forward
we're going to make sure they're not
retaliated we're going to make sure that
they're not intimidated we're going to
make sure they can present the the truth
you also have a situation where many of
these people who were in The Biden uh
influence spear with the influence
peddling scheme they want to come
forward and they want to tell the truth
but not only are they worried about
Biden's lawyers and Democrat politicians
and the media they're also worried about
some of these foreign Nationals that
they've been dealing with look this
money's not coming uh from the the best
and brightest in our adversarial country
this money's coming from Bad actors in
Bad countries and that's why every
American should be concerned that that
we are successful in our investigation
in getting every bit of evidence and
presenting it to the American people
without intimidation or without any type
of of obstruction from this white house
or this Department of Justice well sir
if anyone can do it you can and it is
good that the American people know that
this is happening and you turn the light
on and it does seem to keep people a bit
safer because they're the the countries
at stake here uh chairman James Comer
thank you very much sir I appreciate it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else